so far this is my favorite episode of
House of the dragon from the immaculate
detail of the funeral scene with so many
character interactions the hot debate
between Corliss and rainies about Legacy
and the risk of pursuing it the pure
scale of Veigar and the adrenaline
inducing flight Damon and Ranier are
finally getting together the explosive
family confrontation and the twist
ending with lanor this episode is flat
out stacked with great scenes before
going into all that there are only a few
minor flaws that bugged me a bit that
I'll address now before going into the
outstanding positives the pace between
episodes is still too fast and that's
mainly in regards to our nearer moving
on instantly from Sir Harwin strong it
seemed like she was in love with the man
and the second she hears a word of his
death she immediately turns around and
marries Damon I wish we had a bit of a
moment for them to mourn their father
getting killed but it makes sense
because they can't publicly mourn the
strongs because that essentially
validates the rumors about our kids but
they could have given us a scene of them
doing doing that in private and also the
kids coming to terms with their false
identity like that would have been a
great scene but since the show is moving
so fast we didn't get to see that then
another thing that bothered me in this
episode was a lighting and color grid of
some of the night scenes as an example
in this particular shot you can clearly
tell it's daytime since you can see the
Shadows casted from the Sun they're
giving the footage a cooler temperature
and turning down the exposure to make it
seem like it's almost night time that
fake nighttime aesthetic bothers me but
since most of the episode is supposed to
take place at night I can't really fault
the episode that much I've seen people
compare this to the long night since
both episodes are directed by Miguel
sapochnick but come on one is definitely
a lot darker than the other it just
sucks that some important dialogue takes
place in darkness like or near and
Damon's talk on the beach which going
into that there's one more and final
issue I have is that renira explains to
Damon her relationship with sir Harwin I
wish we actually got to see that
relationship instead of skipping over it
and then just explain cleaning it it is
nice for the writers to acknowledge it
here but due to the scene being at night
we can barely see her Expressions at
times and the sadness that she portrays
is kind of lost because of that however
them both explaining their own
perspectives the night they went out
with each other was very cathartic
because that moment between them was
kind of a question mark then that leads
into the romantic sex scene I don't know
if this moment is upsetting anyone but
come on this wouldn't be a Game of
Thrones worthy follow-up if we didn't
have any incest right after a funeral
looking at the funeral scene I still
don't know how people can call the show
doll by any means the pure efficiency
and storytelling of just characters
looking at each other speaks so many
volumes like vaman delivering his
funeral eulogy and when he starts to
talk about Valerian blood he is staring
directly at renera and her children with
disdain that immediately tells us there
is tension there and he knows that they
aren't true valerians and then this
continues with her realizing that and
getting uncomfortable viserys then
briefly noticing and and then Damon
capping off this whole Moment by
laughing at that fact what otherwise
would be a stereotypical eulogy speech
where vaman would be staring off into
the distance the writers multitask and
established an upcoming conflict which
is the illegitimacy of our nearest
children so there's nothing here to
really make you bored and remain
jawadi's score is absolutely beautiful
too I love to play some of it but yeah
copyright yada yada for the Post funeral
scene there's one aspect here that I
particularly love and that's the
cinematography the shallow Focus gives
the scene a lot of depth because as the
camera rack focuses through the crowd it
reveals to us different characters
staring at each other with varying
Expressions it's basically like knocking
out two to three birds with one stone in
a single shot because we are constantly
seeing so many perspectives and
reactions from different characters
because of this this scene is very
engaging despite it not having a ton of
dialogue and even then the dialogue
between some of the characters like
aegon and the siblings and Damon and
viserys were really good good especially
when aegon was making a joke about not
wanting to marry his sister and just in
general being an absolute Menace there's
also a few moments where the lack of
dialogue is key like when rhaenys walks
past verniera and they don't say
anything to each other essentially
implying that they still heavily dislike
one another and rainey's probably
knowing about the kids I also like the
subtle moment before this where some
random Lord gives their condolences to
raineys but rhaenyra doesn't in
comparison it further makes this moment
even more Awkward I can go on for a
while about how much I like each and
every small and subtle moment but we'd
be here for quite some time to me it's a
testament to how good the writing is and
how the writers don't overly rely on
explaining things to the audience that's
why a lot of these performances are so
captivating because the audience relies
more on watching their acting instead of
relying on the dialogue and before
moving on it's also POG AF that Otto
Hightower is the hand again after the
funeral we then go right into a banger
of a dialogue scene between rainey's and
core or less I think the validation to
how good the scene is comes from the
fact that the people editing the
trailers for the show pulled two quotes
from the scene what is this brief mortal
life if not the pursuit of Legacy
history
does not remember blood
and remembers names I really love the
pairing between cordless and rainey's
because the internal conflict between
them is massive rainey's compassion for
her children makes her put their health
and safety over everything while Corliss
is more obsessed with power and Legacy
that he is blindsided by that and
compromises the safety of his family
they both offer great counterpoints in
the scene and it makes both of them seem
convincing and compelling rhaenius in
particular comes across as very smart
and observant in her taking off the
ignorant blinds covering corliss's eyes
in regards to her nearest children not
being valyrians was a good example of
this even the irony of rain is not
wanting power despite being robbed of it
makes this Dynamic even more interesting
then I also love the cinematography of
these types of scenes where they are
contrasted by a warm fire mix any
profile close-ups of the actors really
pop because of the highlights from the
bright light source looking at the scene
where Eamon tames and flies vegar it
literally blew me away like honestly I
wasn't expecting it to be as crazy yes
it was but the pure skill of vegar was
insane I know we saw her or him I think
it's her in the episode prior but it was
very brief and it was kind of hard to
grasp the true magnitude of her scale
but here Jesus this dragon is a massive
chungus despite the scene being in
darkness I think it still did a good job
showing her size in comparison to the
environment and it's also not too dark
to the point of where you can't see
anything like the fact that Eamon is
basically climbing up a tower to get
onto the dragon was awesome and the big
wide shot to see vegar's full wingspan
was awe-inspiring I couldn't not think
of how to train your dragon in the scene
I think this was a great iteration of it
I'm really happy that HBO spared no
expense here because this was probably a
very expensive scene despite there not
being any major action or battles this
also makes me think back to Game of
Thrones where Daenerys was just hanging
on to the thorny scales of drogon's back
and honestly that seems so unrealistic
in comparison now how did she get enough
grip strength to not get blast off the
dragon from the sheer amount of wind
like I love how they showed how much of
a struggle it was to stay on vegar's
back and it really made the scene much
more suspenseful so when Eamonn finally
learned how to control the dragon it
made it much more satisfying I can't
imagine what future battle scenes will
look like with all these dragons because
ironically it will probably be
significantly more epic than the final
major battle of the long nights which
isn't a hard bar to clear but still it
was supposed to be the biggest battle
moving on to the first climactic
showdown between the greens and the
blacks this scene was utterly riveting
throughout I love the awkward silence in
so many moments because everyone knows
the truth of our nearest children but no
one wants to admit it it's like a weight
that's crushing everyone so when viserys
is desperately trying to hold everything
together it makes his attempts seem
futile because this inherent conflict is
inevitable this build up to me has
perfect tension because we don't know if
aemond is going to ride out Allison's
since they are questioning as to where
he learned that rumors regarding Ramirez
children the writers did a great job in
drawing this out and then aegon
eventually just spilling the beans was
oddly cathartic and in character then
this scene Harkens back to Cersei
demanding equal punishment in season one
where she had the direwolf killed so you
eagerly wait and see if viserys is
infected by Allison's persuasion only
for it to not be and the sudden Twist of
her rushing the child with a blade made
for an outstanding climax to me this
scene is essentially perfect on one hand
you have a master class and buildup of
suspense and then a quick turn to an
explosive ending this is what Peak Game
of Thrones is as this whole conflict is
imbued with an engaging political
shitstorm that is barreling towards a
major Reckoning and the crazy thing is
is that this is just a small taste as of
what is to come so the fact that the
precursor to the dance of the Dragons
which is supposed to be the main event
is still pretty good is impressive then
surprisingly the episode doesn't even
end here and they move on to the fake
out death of Elena valerion I thought
that episode was going to end with
veneer and Demon saying they're going to
kill laner but nope the episode just
keeps on going and getting better I love
the twists the writers did with him not
actually dying and then making the
audience think he burnt to a crisp I was
just starting to really sympathize with
renera and if she killed her husband
after he recommitted himself then I
would have been pretty upset with her
but the twist immediately redeems her
and it's nice to see at least one
character in this universe get a happy
ending but now that Damon or Nero are
together it makes me very excited for
the future of the show their power
Dynamic is going to be so infectious and
I'm 100 ready for it like honestly I
Feel So Satisfied to the point of where
this could have been the season finale
and I would have accepted that if they
didn't do any major time jumps and give
us more episodes thus making the season
1 endpoint here then that would have
been pretty solid but people were
clamoring to get to the Civil War and or
singing the show was boring so whatever
some other noteworthy scenes and moments
is the fight between the children where
I thought Eamon was actually going to
kill one of her Nero's kids Auto
Hightower again lurking in the shadows
like Littlefinger litter is strong
creeping around in the background and
Otto Hightower finally admiring his
daughter there really isn't a bad scene
in this episode and the only flaw I can
attribute to it is the pacing but that's
more of an overall season issue thank
you for watching and let me know what
you thought about episode 7 of House of
the Dragon